le massacre de boudhha indigne les
occidentaux les européens les américains
des centaines de cadavres d'ukrainiens
ont été retrouvés dans cette ville près
de kiev certains ont été exécutés d'une
balle dans la nuque d'autres abattu sur
leur vélo visiblement le président
volodymyr zelensky et sur place à bout
de chasser dans la région de kiev la
capitale ukrainienne le président
dénonce ce massacre et accusent les
forces russes on va l'écouter elle
faisait partie des dirigeants de premier
plan
qu'il est terminé et pouvait déterminer
[Musique]
l'adhésion de l'ukraine à l'otan ainsi
je pense tout ce qui se passe
ce sont des
possibilités
de renforcer les positions de la
fédération de russie de laisser penser à
la fédération de russie
akela l'an patch sur les décisions
européennes et donc maintenant je pense
qu'il convient de faire venir ses
dirigeants pour pouvoir voir les
conséquences de ces jeux avec la
fédération de russie
je pense que l'ukraine
organisera la paix parce que nous sommes
partie de l'europe et nous sommes au 21e
siècle a et notre peuple le peuple
ukrainien a démontré
son caractère et ainsi notre pays a le
droit à la paix la paix ne pourra pas
être là sans la victoire la victoire
doit être et diplomatiques et militaires
grâce aux avancées de notre armée est
bien l'armé une clé nien tous les jours
au gagnant du terrain mais nous voulons
pas perdre une dvi ainsi il convient
d'avoir un dialogue
je pense qu'on ne pouvons pas
parler
et l'essai par lesquelles quelqu'un que
le monde ne pourrait
pas poursuivre en justice tous les
coupables ce serait impossible
ce n'est pas une question d'alliance
c'est une question de davy et il ya eu
des milliers des gens tués et donc
lorsque vous me dites qu'il faut de la
patience pour le tribunal et l' enquête
nous allons tout de même accélérer la
recherche des preuves la recherche des
coupables et je pense que c'est pour le
bien de la civilisation
parce que vous connaissez
vous ne connaissez
voilà le président volodymyr zelensky en
déplacement à butch a lieu de massacre
dit il de dizaines d'ukrainiens le
président accuse nommément les russes
moscou dément sans surprise être
responsable de ce massacre mais ces
corps ont été retrouvés après le départ
des troupes russes de cette région donc
autour de kiev